right so i'm pretty new to the series
i'm just starting book three
we have been so patient so if land
doesn't stab something in the trailer we
we riot
be strong
[Applause]
what the wheel of time turns
and ages come and look so
good
leaving memories
that become legend
why
the power inside you
we protect the world
all right
not a lot of
[Music]
[Music]
the dark one is coming for your friends
[Music]
the last battle is coming
the only thing that matters is what you
do
whatever happens now
oh
oh my god
[Music]
oh my god that felt really short but i
realized it was two minutes oh my god
that all right there's so much i
couldn't easily recognize you know i've
only read the first two books but
i'm surprised there's so much going on
they're really exploring uh book two a
lot you know what i like is that it it
really doesn't look game of thronesy i
just i hope the show isn't too like
corny you know what i mean like what i
love about the wheel of time is how
grounded it is and how realistic it
feels i hope that they keep that tone
you know i get that it's a trailer
they're trying to show a lot of stuff
some of the using of the one power looks
sort of i don't want to say cheap but
just a little corny we have rand and a
gwain showing skin
we got land stabbing stuff so i'm happy
and the music the music is it's got me
hyped it's got me very hyped i'm just i
wish we saw more of the characters like
talking like
like i love seeing the sets i love
seeing the costumes they're very
colorful
i i wish we saw matt and perrin just
like talking you know and annie gwain
and naive that i i wish we saw some of
that i guess i'll just have to wait for
the show because i just want to hear
their voices and see what they're doing
but i get that they're not like the
trailer can't really focus on them
because they're not really selling point
you know this is like moraine and cool
magic system and and all that but i
personally love the really
small stuff the grounded moments the
walking from into in
you know so i'm definitely hyped i
really hope this trailer does good
numbers you know and that people see it
and get excited i'm still
like wanting way more
i feel like this is just like total
reassurance like okay it's not going to
be a train wreck it's gonna be it's
gonna be good there's just so many
questions i have so many questions uh
thank you guys for watching
i like the approach they're going with
yeah bye
[Music]
you